c'est le film québécois antigone de
sophie deraspe qui a été sacré meilleur
film canadien au festival de toronto
alors que la comédie satirique jaujou
rabbit du néo zélandais taika waititi
qui a obtenu le prix du public et pour
en parler je joins magali simard qui est
membre du jury pour le prix du meilleur
premier long métrage canadien et celui
du meilleur film canadien bantam simard
merci d'être avec nous cet après midi
mais c'est vous faut dire que vous avez
déjà été responsable de la programmation
au tiff et quand on doit décerner un
prix comme celui du meilleur film
canadien quels sont les critères la
caisse qui vont influencer le choix du
jury
je dirais que les critères principaux
c'est de trouver les films qui vont se
promener à travers le monde le mieux
possible dans des films à belle facture
esthétique la signature d'artistes
on cherche certainement pas le cinéma
génériques et je veux dire que cette
année on a été choyé pendant sans cela
c'est une année absolument remarquable
et je dois dire qu'en petite couronne
selon moi plante sa fille de ra's planté
un drapeau dans l'histoire du cinéma
québécois c'est incroyable et il y avait
eu six longs métrages canadiens qui ont
été présentés au titre cette année et de
ses 26 y en a huit d'entre eux qui
étaient des premiers longs métrages
est-ce qu'on veut dire que c'est une
bonne année une bonne cuvée pour le
cinéma canadien
excellente année je dirais que même en
commençant regarder les premiers longs
métrages quelques semaines je christine
même si c'était des premiers longs
métrages a fallu que j'aille même mon
histoire mes connaissances personnelles
pour effectivement des premiers longs le
film de mathieu renkin trois nuances
entre celui qui a gagné cette semaine
c'est une pièce est complètement
explosive ça ce qu'on parle pratiquement
à rien dans le cinéma canadien même
international c'est l'histoire de
mackenzie king mais complètement
réinventé et unique en son genre et je
ne peux pas et qu'est ce que ça veut
dire pour la relève un cinéma comme le
thé j'imagine que c'est un grand
tremplin
c'est une grosse plateforme pour les
premiers longs métrages et même les 5e
6e 7e
vous avez mentionné
être une plateforme mondiale à laquelle
le tiff donne accès pour ces thèmes-là
est à peu près quatre cent mille vivent
18 pas mentir c'est le plus gros
festival c'est le sceau du public qu'ils
ont mais c'est aussi les milliers de
journalistes de travers le monde qu'ils
voient ces faits mineurs qui en parle
qui écrivit qui seront ensuite
distribués dans les pédiatres allemand
est une immense présence d'industries
dangereux ici c'est l'amour du cinéma
mais c'est aussi la business du cinéma
valeur égale pour ces femmes-là etc des
deux côtés c'est sur un prix au tiff
c'est une excellente carte de visite
j'aimerais qu'on parle du prix du public
lui s'était emporté vous l'avez dit par
le film du réalisateur takao waikiki
giorgio rabbit et on remarque aussi avec
le prix du public à toronto bell ca
c'est annonciateur en un certain succès
pas mal plus que le festival de cannes
par exemple
effectivement il ya plus de cinéma
commercial je dirais de cinéma
anglophones à toronto donc pour tous les
distributeurs et artistes derrière des
films qui veulent avoir une grosse
présence ou qui souhaitent avoir une
grande présence dans la saison des galas
des prix qui commencent toujours en
septembre si le début donc c'est très
prisé d'essayer d'avoir le prix du
public parce que des critiques partout
au monde et dans tous les festivals mais
un prix du public pour le plus gros
public au monde un film ça veut dire
beaucoup les torontois et ceux
d'ailleurs qui vient des touristes
libyens dans les faits seuls et qu'ils
votent pour ce prix là sont très
astucieux c'est une audience qui connaît
beaucoup de cinéma et qui a pratiquement
toujours faire des bons choix dans sans
souci les films qui ont gagné le prix du
public sera très loin dans je dirais que
pour djurdjura bits c'est le début de
quelque chose de très grand satan avec
ce film là et pour l'avoir vu moi même
c'est un film excessivement
irrévérencieux très drôle mais une
comédie ce rythme l'on s'attend jamas ah
ouais alors que ça marche complètement
donc je l'applaudis public d'avoir su
porter quelque chose d'aussi ou d'un
succès et je veux vous jeu
reste quelques secondes j'aimerais vous
demander qu'est ce qui est à retenir de
ce 44e festival madame simard et j'aurai
les nouvelles voies cinématographique
c'est ça le but dans le fin fond de but
des festivals c'est la découverte
d'artistes est allé voir des milliers de
personnes qui sont en ligne des
centaines de personnes qui sont en lice
pour des premiers longs métrages de
partout au monde s'est personnellement
ce qui me touche le plus c'est
l'engouement pour l'or et point la ligne
ne souffrent pas de noms connus dans ces
films là donc c'est selon moi ce qui en
sort le plus sûr énormément donc des
découvertes et l'amour du cinéma magali
simard je rappelle êtes membre du jury
pour le prix du meilleur premier long
métrage canadien celui du meilleur film
canadien merci d'avoir prétendu parler
cet après midi mais en fait vous